Transcriber: Ilayda Gokgoz
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Böyle gardımı alıp gelmiş
gibi hissediyorum.
En azından heyecanımı bastırmak adına.
Merhaba hoş geldiniz.
Hiçbir şeyi yapmak dışında bir çareniz
olmadığını düşündünüz mü ?
Ama öyle zorunluluktan değil.
Acıkmış gibi, susamış gibi.
Hatta bazen size zarar verdiğini
bile önemsemeden.
Bir gün hiç unutmuyorum.
Sahnedeyim o an
darbuka çalıyorum, darbukamın üzerinin
pembeleştiğini fark ettim.
Bir şeyler damlıyor diye düşünüp etrafa
bakarken gözlerim ellerime kitlendi.
Parmak uçlarım çatlamış, minik
minik kanıyor ama o an
salgıladığım adrenalin, oksitosin,
o heyecanla hiç acı hissetmiyorum
ve o şekilde 45 dakika daha
çalmaya devam ettim.
Ama böyle bitsin diye sabır ederek değil,
aynı coşkuyla, yarınlar yokmuşçasına.
Ben de tutkunun tanımı böyle bir şey.
Biraz sert bir giriş oldu.
Aslında işimle ilgili çok daha eğlenceli
anılarım var genellikle.
Bu bir de birazcık başlardaydı.
Zamanla kondisyonunuz arttıkça, tekniğiniz
geliştikçe, birazcıkta elleriniz
nasırlaştıkça böyle durumlar azalıyor.
Ben multidisipliner perküsyonistim
yani dünya vurmalı çalgılarına
ilgiliyim ama ana enstrümanlarım
darbuka ve handpan.
Gözlerinizi kapatın.
Darbuka çalan birini hayal edin.
Eminim o fotoğraftaki kişiye benzemiyorum.
Hikayem de biraz farklı aslında.
Çoğu üstadım, arkadaşlarım genelde
mahalli kültürden,
çocukluktan çalarak yetişmişler.
Bunu bu arada çok şanslı buluyorum.
Benim birazcık daha geç oldu çalmaya
başlamam.
Üniversitede çok sesli bir vurmalı
çalgılar topluluğundaydım.
Orada farklı bir enstrüman çalarken
bir an elime darbukayı aldım.
Sevgili hocam Selçuk Yüksel, tuşemin yani
vurduğunda ses çıkartma kapasitemin çok
iyi olduğunu söyledi.
Devam etmemi önerdi.
Ben de zaten darbuka çalmayı
çok sevmiştim.
Çalmaya devam ettim.
Bol bol çaldım.
Ama yine çok kıymetli hocamız Mısırlı
Ahmet'in dünyaya armağan ettiği bir
teknikle çalıyoruz biz darbukayı.
Hatta dünyadaki çoğu profesyonel
de bu teknikle çalıyor.
Darbukayı
o teknikte de çalarken sol
elinizin çok önemi var.
Asıl sol elinizi çok aktif
kullanmanız gerekiyor.
Ben,
ilk önce sol elimin varlığını
o gün öğrenmiş gibiydim.
Gerçekten inanılmaz zorlandım
ama yılmadım.
Her gün oturup sol elimi terbiye
etmeye başladım.
İlk önce basit egzersizlerle
çalışmaya başladım.
Sonra günden güne o değişimi görmek bana
inanılmaz bir yaşam tecrübesi kattı.
Ben hiç bir zaman bir domatesin
gelişimini görmemiştim.
Çiçekten o pembeleşmesi, kızarması
sonrasında bir meyve haline gelmesi,
o yüzden öyle yeşermek gibi, meyve vermek
gibi bir his geldi içime ve hayata dair
artık her şeyi uğraşırsam
yapabileceğimi hissettim.
Bu da gerçekten büyük bir
özgüven getiriyor.
Aslında size de söylemek
istediğim en çok bu.
Eğer tutku duyduğunuz, çok istediğiniz ama
zorlanacağınızı düşündüğünüz bir
şey varsa lütfen üzerine gidin.
Yani düzenli aralıklarda kendinizi
ona maruz bırakın eminim
geri dönüşünü alacaksınız.
Benim de o şekilde oldu ve özgüven ve
cesaret demişken, ben pandemi döneminde
Eskişehir Büyükşehir Belediyesi vurmalı
çalgılar gruplarının şefliğini bıraktım.
Kurumsal hayatımı bırakarak kendi bireysel
sahnelerimi yapmaya karar verdim.
Ve yola çıkarken bir manifestom vardı.
Daha batılı müzik altyapılarına,
bizim değerlerimizden, bizim
topraklarımızdan, topraklarımız derken
gerçekten topraklarımız yani topraktan
yapılmış bir darbukayla
eşlik etmeye başladım.
Aslında geniş bir setupımız var.
Klasik müzik, R&B müzik,
afro house elektronik altyapılara
darbuka çalmaya başladım, ama darbuka
dışında da geniş bir vurmalı çalgılar
setupı kurduk.
Ana karakterlerden biri darbukaydı.
Düşündüğümüzden çok daha hızlı bir şekilde
ilgi görmeye başladı hem dünyada
hem ülkemizde.
Bu aslında çok da beklemediğimiz bir
durumdu ama bu duruma çok heyecanlandık,
mutlu olduk.
Yine DJ arkadaşım Utku Karahan ile
birlikte kendi konseptimizi oluşturduk.
Bunun da çok fazla sahne
getirisi oldu bize.
Bu yoğunluk gerçekten bizi yormaya başladı
ama her gün aynı motivasyonla,
aynı enerjiyle sahnede olmayı ben yine
vurmalı enstrümanlara bağlıyorum.
Çünkü fiziksel anlamda bir şeye vurarak
ses çıkartmak bence insan psikolojisine
iyi geliyor.
Zaten tarihte de birçok toplum da dini
ritüellerde vurmalı enstrümanlar
kullanılmış.
Hatta insanlar ayinlerde bedenlerine
vurarak ritmik sesler çıkartıp
ibadet etmişler.
Bunu sadece ses ve vurmalı enstrümanlar
bağlamında bakmayabiliriz.
Basketbol oynayan biri var mı bilmiyorum
ama topun her seferinde yere ve ele
teması sırasında çıkarttığı ses de bence
o rahatlatıcı hisse etkiye sahip.
Şu an günümüzde biliyorsunuz çok popüler
olan spritüel disiplinlerde de meditasyon
sırasında aslında size nefesinize
odaklanmanızı söylerler.
Her nefes alışverişiniz, her günün doğuşu
ve batışı, denizin dalgalarının kıyıya
vuruşu ve geri gelişi aslında
ritmik tekrarlardan oluşur.
Ritmik tekrarlar, hayatınızda bir
odaklanma probleminiz varsa onun temeline
oturtabileceğiniz, sizi rahatlatan
odaklanma probleminizi hepimiz gibi
çağımızın getirisi olan odaklanma
problemini aslında rahatlatacaktır.
Ve ben de kendi meditasyon aracım olan
gerçekten ufo gibi
bir enstrümandan bahsetmek istiyorum size.
Ben tutkularım için yola çıktım ama
yolda çok daha büyük bir
tutkumla karşılaştım.
Handpan, daha önce gördünüz mü bilmiyorum
ama çok daha genç bir enstrüman.
Benim karşılaşmam da 2013 yılında bir
Facebook gönderisi sırasında
olmuştu onunla, düşünün o zaman
Facebook kullanıyorum.
Ben çok heyecanlanmıştım ama o video
yayınlandığında aslında bulunduğu anlar
da yayınlanmıştı ve seri üretimi yoktu.
Benim olabileceğini düşünmemiştim bile.
Sonra birkaç yıl sonra.
Üretici bir firmanın reklamlarıyla
karşılaştım ve bir şekilde benim olmasını
çok istedim.
Ama çok yaygın bir enstrüman
olmadığı için inanılmaz pahalı.
Ben de üniversite son sınıf öğrencisiyim.
Benim bütçemin çok üstündeydi.
Bir şekilde aldım.
O alma sürecimi anlatsam aslında başlı
başına bir TED konuşması olabilir.
Çünkü tamamen kendi imkanlarımla
çalışarak, ek derslerle tamamen yaşam
motivasyonumu ona odaklandığım bir
şekilde aldım ve asıl bana geliş
sürecini paylaşmak istiyorum.
Her gelen
günde, her saatte, şu an hangi depoda,
hangi şehirde, hangi ülkede diye kontrol
etmeye başladım.
Hatta sonuna doğru şöyle düşündüm.
O süreci o kadar sevdim ve
heyecanla bekledim ki acaba
1-2 gün daha uzasa mı?
Çünkü bu his de çok keyifliymiş
diye düşünmeye başladım.
Sonra bana geldi ve o buluşma anının
hissi bambaşkaydı.
O kadar mutlu oldum ki hemen
çalmaya başladım.
Ama daha güzel çalmak istiyorum, daha
profesyonel çalmak istiyorum bir yandan.
Dünya üzerinde bununla ilgili
bir öğreti yoktu.
Eğitim videosu yoktu.
Eğitim veren herhangi biri
yoktu.
Ülkemizde zaten ilk handpan
kullanıcılarından biriyim
belki o dönemde 1-2 kişide daha
vardı ama biz birbirimizden haberdar
değildik.
O şekilde yine eğitim videoları yoktu
ama performans videolarını izleyerek
yine sosyal medyadan birazcık fikir
sahibi olmaya başladım.
Ve ne oldu biliyor musunuz?
Hani terbiye etme, terbiye etmeye
zorlandığım sol elim var ya ben darbukada
kullandığım tekniği bu topraklarda
doğan, darbuka çalan bir Ceren olarak
handpan üzerinde uygulamaya başladım.
Ve bu şekilde kendi ekolümü yarattım.
Aldığım enstrümanla sürekli videolar
çekip sosyal medyama koydum ve ikinci
paylaşımımda bunu dünyada
iki üreten firma vardı.
Bir tanesi benimle çalışmak istedi ve bana
bir sürü enstrüman yolladılar.
Bu his tarif edilemez bir duygu ve ben
hepsini aynı heyecanla bekledim.
Şu an,
bir Alman, bir İtalyan firmanın
global artistiyim.
Onların hem ticari anlamda bir
işbirliğimiz var onlarla hem de sanatsal
yönden temsilcisiyim.
Beni çok
etkileyen bir süreçti ve şunu
söylemek istiyorum.
Ben bunları kendi sosyal medya
platformlarımda yayınlayarak insanlara,
kitlelere, farklı ülkelerdeki
insanlara ulaştırdım.
Yani beni öne çıkartacak bir otöre,
bir güce ihtiyacım yoktu.
Ben yeni nesilden çok umutluyum.
Şu an gelen kuşaklardan çok umutluyum.
Biz teknolojiyle iç içe büyüdük.
Onlar bu teknolojinin içine doğdular.
Belki bunları şimdi söylemek
istediklerini, yapmak istediklerini
gösterecekleri kendi sosyal medya
platformlarını oluşturacaklar.
O yüzden siz de benim içimde yanan
bir ateş, bir yangın vardı.
Ben sadece onu harlayıp,
parlamasına izin verdim.
Sizin de böyle bir ateşiniz varsa lütfen
insanlara göstermekten, paylaşmaktan,
ateşinizi ortak etmekten kaçınmayın.
Şimdi kendi bestem olan birkaç
circle paylaşacağım sizinle.
Buraya çıkan birçok arkadaşım aslında
işini konuşarak yapıyor.
Ben belki ilk defa konuşuyorum
yine büyük kitlelere
bir sahne performansı icra ediyorum ama
çoğu kişi sesimi merak ediyordu.
Konuşmak benim için gerçekten zordu.
O yüzden herhangi bir hatam
olduysa kusura bakmayın.
Çok teşekkür ederim beni
dinlediğiniz için.
Çok teşekkür ederim.
Sağolun.